hey guys so we just got a cooking class
we're here in Hawaii on lanai it's this
really really small island I think the
population is only three thousand people
so here's one of the plates this is my
plate I'll show you
Ryan's plate only I could actually cook
like this like when he busted out the
blender I was like this is what I'm
talking about
anyway here is a quick little video of
the learning process I hope you guys
enjoy let's lay down this side okay
calmly Oulu so bad not how you doing
fine so I can tell us your first time in
a professional kitchen or any then it's
cute okay you do it you use it as like a
forest I suggest well we're going to use
now the blender
since I might need I got less fish fishy
fish and cookin over there
fishy fishy I was gonna fill myself
eating my food but I started shoveling
it into my face because it was so good
god it's completely gone it was
delicious it was so good and now we will
finish up cooking one last little thing
and then I'm gonna need a serious nap
you should survive the rest of the day
cuz I'm so full let me what you guys
think I should cook as soon as I get
back home not gonna cook any of that
because it's too professional I'm not
ready for it bleeding tools decided to
cuz that means I get some good meal yeah
yeah I bet it works out for you too
oh we're off to vacation for my birthday
I'm almost done packing